John Lewis is a Retail Group under a
cloud it's private club on the banks of
the Thames the scenic setting for a
difficult meeting for chairwoman Dame
Sharon White
facing votes of confidence in her
leadership from staff known as partners
who also own the business she sought to
reassure them they would remain the boss
the John Lewis partnership will always
be an employee-owned business
a model is the very reason I joined the
partnership
because I believe profoundly in an
approach of Kinder capitalism in the
21st century that demonstrates our
ability to combine commercial Excellence
with social purpose
it was enough to win their support to
take the company forward but not to
avoid defeat on her performance last
year when John Lewis lost more than 230
million pounds and she raised the
prospect of seeking outside investment
for the first time for the former boss
of media regulator ofcom who has no
previous retail experience it's a
rebellion that increases questions about
her leadership I personally believe that
you have to have an absolute focus on
the trading success when the glory years
of journalists many people have been
very kind about the years where we were
doing very well and getting a good
Financial return it was an absolute
Obsession on satisfying our customers
for decades of retail Bellwether that
clothed furnished and reflected middle
class Britain John Lewis has been hit by
competition online and the High Street
while it's waitrose customers have
sought cheaper options the reality is
that when we get to a cost of living
prices what matters is the best prices
all the time and you know what value do
we put on value so I think that's an
interesting question about how much
we're prepared to pay but unless John
Lewis reminders why they're better why
they're different and why it's worth
shopping with them we will disappear
John Lewis's business model is unique it
gives its staff benefits like access to
this place and the power to hold
management to account now these votes
were non-binding purely symbolic but
they are a clear expression of concern
about whether the current leadership has
the know-how to preserve what makes it
different in a harsh business
environment
from Crockery to Christmas ads John
Lewis is an institution but it wouldn't
be the first to discover there's no room
for sentiment on the High Street Paul
Kelso Sky News in cookham